Welcome back.
In this presentation I'm just
going to do a bunch of examples
of taking the antiderivative or
the indefinite integral of
polynomial expressions, and
hopefully I'll show you that
it's a pretty straightforward
thing to do.
So let's get started.
If I wanted to take indefinite
integral-- and you could do a
web search for integral and
you'll see this drawn
properly-- take the indefinite
integral-- let me make
a big expression.
Let's say I want to take the
indefinite integral of 3x to
the negative 5 minus 7x
to the third plus 3
minus x to the ninth.
So you might already
be intimidated by
what I wrote down.
Well, one, if you saw the
last presentation or if you
understood presentation, you
probably realize, well the
indefinite integral even
though it looks like fancy
math isn't that fancy.
Or at least it isn't that
difficult to perform.
And all you have to realize now
is if we took the derivative of
a polynomial, it was just the
sum of the derivatives
of each of the terms.
it actually it turns out is the
same way the other way around.
The antiderivative of this
entire expression is just the
sum of the antidervatives of
each of the individual terms.
So we can just take
the [? integers ?]
of each term and we'll
get the answer.
So what does this equal?
Well in this case 3x
to the minus 5 power.
So we take the exponent, we add
1 to the exponent, so now we
get x to the negative 4, and
then we multiply the
coefficient times 1
over the new exponent.
So 1 over the new
exponent is minus 1/4.
So 3 times minus
1/4 is minus 3/4.
And let's see.
Here we have x to the third.
So instead of x to the third,
let's raise it by one number.
So we get x to the fourth.
And then we multiply
the coefficient.
You know, we could either just
keep the minus and say the
coefficient's 7, or we could
just say the coefficient
is minus 7.
We multiply the coefficient
times 1 over the new exponent.
So the new exponent is 4,
so we multiply 1/4 times
minus 7, so minus 7/4.
And now this is interesting.
3, just 3.
Well how do we apply this?
Well isn't 3 the same thing
as 3 times x to the 0?
Right, because x to
the 0 is just 1.
And that's how you
should view it.
It shows you that this rule
is actually very consistent.
So what's the answer
derivative of 3?
Well if we view 3 as 3 x to the
0, we raise the exponent by
1, so now we're going
to have x to the 1.
And x to the 1 is just
x, so I'm just going
to leave it as an x.
And we multiply it, the old
coefficient-- this 3 or you
know the derivative
coefficient-- we multiply that
times 1 over the inverse
of the new exponent.
So the exponent's 1, so
the inverse of 1 is 1,
so it just stays 3.
We've multiplied 3 times
1/1, which is still just 3.
And then finally x to the
ninth-- I think you're getting
the hang of this-- we raise the
exponent by one,
x to the tenth.
And then we multiply the
current coefficient.
Well the current coefficient
is minus 1, right.
We just didn't
write the 1 there.
We multiply the current
coefficient minus 1 times
1 over the new exponent,
so it's minus 1/10.
There we did it.
That wasn't too difficult of
taking the antiderivative
or-- I always forget.
Plus c, right?
Because when you take the
derivative of any constant
it becomes 0, so it might
have disappeared here.
So plus c where this
is any constant.
This could be a 10, could
be a million, could
be a minus trillion.
It's any constant.
And just to really hit the
point home, let's take the
derivative of this and just
make sure we got
this expression.
And hopefully this is second
nature to you by now.
And you know if you ever run
out of practice problems
in your book because you
love doing math so much,
just make up problems.
That's what I'm doing.
I do this even when I'm not
recording videos, just for fun.
So let's take the
derivative of this.
Minus 4 times this coefficient.
Minus 4 times minus 3/4 is 3x.
Then we subtract 1 from
this exponent, minus 5.
And then 4 times 4 is minus 7 x
to the-- we take 1 from this
exponent-- x to the third.
And I promise you I'm not
even looking up here.
I know you might think, well
Sal, he's just looking up here,
but no I'm actually in my head
at least working through this.
And then plus the
derivative of 3x.
Well the derivative of 3x is
3-- is almost second nature
now, but you can kind of
do this-- is 3x to the 1.
And you say 1 times 3
is 3 times x to the 0.
And then 10 times minus 1/10.
Well that's just minus 1.
x to the 1 less than 10, so x
to the ninth, plus-- what's the
derivative of any constant?
Right, it's 0.
You could almost do this
constant as some number
times x to the 0.
And if you took the derivative,
well you multiply the 0
times c and you get 0.
Well, you might get minus
1 depending on how
you're doing it.
But that's actually kind of
an interesting question.
OK I'll stop digressing.
But you get a 0 here, and if
you simplify that, that just
equals 3x to the minus 5
minus 7x to the third plus
3 minus x to the ninth.
Think we have time for one
more problem like this.
I think you probably got this.
This is probably one of the
more straightforward things
you'll learn in mathematics.
And in future presentations
I'll give you more of an
intuition of why the
antiderivative is useful.
We're learning the indefinite
integral, but we could learn to
use the definite integral,
which we'll learn in a couple
of presentations to figure out
things like the area under
curve, or the volume of
a rotational figure.
Well I don't confuse
you too much.
Let's do one more problem.
I won't make this one as hairy.
So the integral of negative
1/2x to the minus 3
plus 7x to the fifth.
Let's start with this
term of the polynomial.
We raise the exponent one,
so x to the minus 2 now,
right, because we added
one to negative 3.
And then we multiply 1 over
this new exponent times
the old coefficient.
And actually I'll write
out all the steps.
So the old coefficient
is minus 1/2.
So this is a minus 2.
Minus 2 so we multiply
it times minus 1/2.
Let me switch colors back.
Plus we raise the exponent by
one, x to the sixth, and we
multiply the old coefficient
times 1 over the new
coefficient, times 1/6.
And so what's the answer?
Well what's minus 1/2
times minus 1/2?
Well that's positive
1/4 x to the minus 2.
Oh, and of course, plus c.
As you can tell, this is
my main source of missing
points on calculus quizzes.
1/4 x to the minus 2 plus
7/6 x to the sixth plus c.
There you go.
And if you wanted to take the
derivative, minus 2 times 1/4
is minus 2/4 which is minus
1/2 x to the minus 3.
And then 6 times 7/6 is 7x.
And then you decrease
the exponent by one,
x to the fifth.
And the derivative of
our constant is 0.
And then we get our
original expression.
Hopefully at this point you're
pretty comfortable taking a
derivative of a polynomial, and
then given a polynomial you can
actually take the
antiderivative, go
the other way.
And never forget to
do your plus c.
And I hope you understand why
we have to put that constant
there, because when you take an
antiderivative, you don't know
whether the original thing that
you the derivative of I guess
had a constant there, because
the constant's derivative is 0.
Hopefully I confused you
with that last statement.
I'll see you in the next
presentation and I'll show you
how to reverse the chain rule.
See you soon.